[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENA HAINES: Hi.
I'm Hena Haines, and I'm here
from the Google Mountain View
headquarters.
And we just made it to Milwaukee
to meet with Harley-Davidson
to see how they're using
the Maps API to help
riders plan their rides.
MALE SPEAKER: The
technology that's
coming in now if we're
on the bikes, it's great.
It really helps out.
It gets your turns
ahead of time.
It keeps you away from
the four wheelers.
It does a great job.
HEIDI SKINNER: We love our
partnership with Google
simply because it's a
really familiar platform
that all customers use
on a day-to-day basis.
And we want to use technology
and great innovative partners
to help our riders experience
the ride and adventure.
The Ride Planner application
does a lot for our customers,
and Google Places
and Google Maps
layered on top of that really
make it all come together.
MALE SPEAKER: There's
something about getting
from A to B on a motorcycle.
Especially for me,
a Harley-Davidson,
there's nothing else.
I look at it as a partnership.
I tell it what I
want to do, and I
know it's going to get me home.
That's a great feature
about all of that.
HEIDI SKINNER: We've
got riders that
need directions
around the block,
and we've got riders
that take trips
of 10,000 or 20,000 miles,
and Google makes it so easy
for them to plan a ride.
[MUSIC PLAYING]